[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
la semaine a été agitée particulier à la
france a soumise elle a été aussi pour
le syndicat force ouvrière dont le
secrétaire pascal pavageau a démissionné
six mois après son arrivée
après la révélation d'un fichage très
polémique des cadres de son syndicat
alors après cet épisode nous allons nous
interroger aujourd'hui sur le rôle sur
le poids réel des syndicats après le
bras de fer perdu à la sncf et au moment
où s'ouvre la réforme des retraites pour
nous dire si les syndicats certes encore
à quelque chose nous avons invité
philippe texier bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le secrétaire du comité bourgogne
franche comté de la cgt lors nicolaï
bonjour vous êtes vous là secrétaire
général de la cfdt pour la bourgogne
franche comté troisième représentant
syndical bonjour et de leurs héros
bonjour vous êtes le secrétaire de force
ouvrière en côte-d'or et vous avez donc
vécu cette semaine particulière pour
votre syndicat et puis nous profiterons
de l'éclairage de dominique andolfatto
bonjour bonjour vous êtes professeur en
sciences politiques à l'université de
bourgogne franche comté spécialiste du
syndicalisme votre dernier ouvrage
s'appelle la démocratie sociale en
tension c'est un peu notre sujet du jour
alors cette démission de pascal pavageau
je le disais en ouverture elle dit quoi
edouard guerrero de votre syndicat qu'il
est miné par des luttes qu'il a du mal à
se trouver une identité
vous vous l'interprétez comment alors je
vais pas pouvoir dire vos grand chose
tout a été dit tout a été écrit dans les
médias la seule chose que je peux vous
dire sur le sujet aujourd'hui c'est que
nos instances vont faire on prend toutes
les dispositions pour régler cette crise
vous savez les crises à force ouvrière
on en a vécu d'autres
historiquement on a déjà vécu plusieurs
et à chaque fois nous avons mis en place
les instances les instances ont saisi de
cette crise et ont réglé les
problématiques inter dans deux de
l'organisation
g je vais vous dire juste simplement
quelque chose les hommes passent et les
organisations vont rester et c'est les
combats que mènent les orients sur
syndicales qui sont importantes aux aux
yeux aux yeux des de nos adhérents et de
nous servir on nous dira pas si c'est
dit quelque chose ce qui se passe dans
le syndicat dominique andolfatto vous
qui les observaient les syndicats
ce qui se passe là c'est nouveau c'est
arrivé souvent dans la vie des syndicats
où le ca a dit quelque chose de nouveau
sur des divisions et peut-être sur la
faiblesse de deux syndicats non ça dit
c'est quand même s'est amené pour fo
c'est un événement relativement nouveau
jeu j'ai pas souvenir que secrétaire
général fo soit parti en démissionnant
surtout moins de six mois après sa
nomination
ça parle aussi de détention qui au sein
de fo il ya différents qui va géologique
il ya des gens qui sont curés fourmiz
d'autres des militants qui sont plus que
plus anarchiste plus trotsky sédentaire
il ya un problème de fond après les
mythologiques un problème de ligne
ensuite il ya un second problème quel
problème du management de l'organisation
sa gouvernance un syndicat c'est pas une
entreprise c'est c'est une association
égalité donc on ne peut pas le dirigeant
doit parfois passer des compromis donc
il ya gagne au style de management est
également qui a été sanctionné je pense
philippe texier la cgt a vécu ça aussi
avec thierry le paon et vous l'avez vécu
près d'ailleurs ce sujet là est ce qu'on
est
si on prend de la hauteur dans des
luttes pour le pouvoir simplement et ça
on peut le trouver dans une entreprise
on peut trouver dans un parti on peut
trouver dans plein de choses ou est-ce
qu'on est dans aussi quand ça arrive
dans des luttes de clans entre des gens
qui ont des visions différentes de
l'action syndicale
je pense qu'on est dans une situation
pour le syndicalisme ou en fait
lorsqu'on existe depuis pour nous en
tout cas depuis 120 ans que en
permanence dans les syndicats
il ya un débat sur pas sur les valeurs
sûres ce qui nous a marqués en termes de
rôle dans la société c'est à dire la
défense des intérêts matériels et moraux
des salariés et bien sûr la la stratégie
à conduire
comment se rassembler comment construire
un rapport avec les salariés pour
construire les revendications sur quelle
base est ce qu on le fait avec les
autres syndicats
quelles sont les priorités revendicative
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la question de
l'égalité professionnelle par exemple
n'est pas quelque chose qui sur lequel
on doit être plus à l'initiative
beaucoup plus présent est ce que ce sont
les questions par exemple de démocratie
dans l'entreprise
est ce qu'il est normal que les
entreprises soient soudés décision
seulement des actionnaires vous c'est
plus des différences idéologiques des
des luttes pour le pouvoir pour le
pouvoir c'est un débat sur le sens et le
rôle de l'intervention des syndicats
dans sa volonté de rechercher une
efficacité mais il y avait ça par
exemple dans le fait qu en même temps
thierry le paon on lui reproche d'avoir
mis trop d'argent dans un bureau dans un
logement de fonction ou dans des bureaux
je vois pas tellement où est la
différence idéologique là dedans mais ça
c'est des arguments qui ont été poussés
en interne et qui ont été repris à
foison dans les médias pour cacher un
vrai débat sur le sens et la démarche de
l'ancien et jean-eric accord sur ce
qu'ils devaient faire de leur syndicat
si vous l'avez c'est le débat qu'on doit
voir mais lorsqu'il prend des formes qui
dépasse l'organisation elle même et qui
sont sur la place publique et du coup il
ya eu des réponses de trouver et
aujourd'hui on a une cgt qui continuait
du coup à se poser d'autres questions
c'est celle donc du coup de l'efficacité
revendications et on va y venir leur
nicolaï en début de semaine laurent
berger secrétaire national avait lui
incité pas ce qu'elle paraît jouer à
partir à mots couverts mais c'était un
petit peu ça alors est-ce que comment
vous l'interprétez c'était tactique
parce que il ya une fois il peut y avoir
une forme de ridder de rivalité ou
est-ce que c'était aussi on peut le
comprendre comme ça dans l'intérêt du
monde syndical c'est à dire qu'il
fallait arrêter les frais de change de
déballage interne parce que ça affaiblit
c'est le monde syndical dont on dit déjà
qu'il n'est pas aussi fort qu'il l'était
précédemment
alors je peux pas vous dire ce que
laurent avait en tête à ce moment là
quand il a rencontré pascal pavageau
mais je pense que c'était tout
simplement un conseil d'oman homme ou en
tout cas une opinion de d'un dirigeant
un autre dirigeants d'organisations
syndicales mais de toute façon quand il
y à du chaos dans une organisation
syndicale
ça ne sert absolument pas les autres
organisations syndicales on a tout
intérêt évidemment a montré un
syndicalisme cohérent offensif c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire à la cfdt
et ça ne nous apporte absolument rien et
ça ne nous satisfait absolument pas
quand les autres organisations
syndicales sont en difficulté de cet
ordre là pour finir sur ce sujet
dominique andolfatto vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure en disant il ya des
courants et des choses que les gens
voient pas forcément on a effectivement
entendu dans cette affaire qui a une
elle lambertiste à force ouvrière les
lambertistes c'est jean vraiment à
l'extrême gauche on est étonné de
de d'apprendre ça en se disant ben c'est
pas l'image qu'on a d'un syndicat des
parce que l'extrême gauche elle refuse
aussi le système économique le système
social et un certain nombre de
fonctionnement actuel et pourtant c'est
vrai il ya à l'intérieur des syndicats
des forces qui sont peut-être
politiquement située beaucoup plus loin
que le positionnement moyen du syndicat
oui dans tous les syndicats dans toute
organisation d'ailleurs politiques ou
syndicales il ya des courants il ya des
tendances donc il faut est caractérisée
par par ces tendances
la raison d'être des fois l'ogc nice est
l'anti communisme mais au fur et à
mesure du temps il ya donc des gens que
le plus tôt des lamberti des trotskistes
également des anarchistes qui représente
enfin edouard guerrero pourrait
peut-être nous dire non au moins 20 %
d'aidés des mandats dans cette
organisation
beaucoup de secrétaires généraux
d'ailleurs se sont fait élire la tête de
fo en s'appuyant sur ce courant mailly
blondel avant lui et c'est il ya un mais
il ya également une aile réformiste
assez dur qui est qui est assez
puissante notamment à la fédération de
la métallurgie sakho edouard barreiro à
l'intérieur d'un syndicat on doit tenir
compte
là c'est vous parce que c'est faux cap
est en crise cette semaine on doit tenir
compte de ça c'est à dire de l'influent
ce qu'ils sont des influences plus plus
forte que la ligne médiane et que ce que
les gens voient l'extérieur alors nous
avons un syndicat force ouvrière qui est
un syndicat monsieur andolfatto l'a dit
tout de suite qui est traversée par des
courants mais c'est partout ça c'est
dans la vie c'est dans la vie des
courants les courants politiques y en a
partout et dans une organiste radical y
en a forcément vous prenez le
fonctionnement de notre organisation
syndicale force ouvrière par exemple
revenons un petit peu à ce qui s'est
passé au mois d'avril au congrès au
congrès de lille nous n'avons que rien
caché à personne
4000 délégués 3500 à 4000 personnes
premiers 500 délégués cinq semaines cinq
jours de congrès deux jours deux
interventions libres sans filtre à la
disposition et de grande tension entre
jean claude maillet sans succès mais
voilà donc nous avons vous avez pu
constater que force ouvrière n'a rien
caché il n'y a pas eu de tabous etc
vous avez pu voir les interventions des
uns des unes et des autres
ça a été très clair il y a eu des
discussions dans l'organisation et à la
fin de ce congrès nous
vos élus des instances qui dans ces
instances ont élu le secrétaire général
et est sorti pascal pavageau parce que
il avait le soutien de la majorité de la
grande grande grande majorité des
syndicats traversée par découvre
différents mais l'objet c'était délire
après l'actualité on va venir au coeur
finalement de ceux dont on voulait
parler aujourd'hui avec un peu d'ironie
on a titré cette émission des syndicats
certes il encore à quelque chose parce
que la question se pose et elle s'est
posée de façon avec beaucoup d'acuité
après ce ce conflit à la sncm un conflit
long où tous les syndicats étaient pas
d'accord il ya eu beaucoup de
manifestations il ya eu beaucoup de
grèves il y avait une grande
impopularité dans l'opinion pour final
on a l'impression que les syndicats ont
pas réussi à empêcher ce qui se passait
philippe texier c'est quoi c'était une
défaite en rase campagne pour les
syndicats une des première très grosse
défaite en rase campagne ou de votre
point de vue pas pas vraiment je trouve
que c'est déjà la défaite d'un
gouvernement puisque un an plus d'un an
après l'élection du de maquereaux et la
mise en place de ce gouvernement
il met en oeuvre des réformes et qui
reçoit déjà un opinion défavorable
important dans la population
ça a été le cas sur la réforme nouvelle
réforme ferroviaire avec une
mobilisation des cheminots dans un cadre
unitaire important on m'autorise à vous
dire que vous pratiquez la même langue
de bois que l'algérie parce que la
réforme elle était la grève était très
impopulaire dans l'opinion quand on
quand on prenait tous les sondages par
la réforme la réforme avait été un peu
plus vert chez les salariés mais pas
dans la musculation mais je vais aller
au bout de ma démonstration c'est qu'en
fait moi je me souviens j'ai le souvenir
aussi d' y compris sur vos antennes d'un
nombre important d'usagers qui non
seulement qui était évidemment dans des
gênes occasionnées par une mobilisation
original puisqu'on se rappelle du cycle
de grève de deux jours tourne tous les
cinq jours donc quitter là pour empêcher
un blocage mais donc du coup de
continuer à peser dans une négociation
qu'on savait qu'elle est longue avec ce
gouvernement responsable et ressasser
cette mobilisation a permis une reprise
importante de la dette par l'état alors
que vous saviez qu'un des problèmes
importants de cette entreprise sait qu
elle croulait sous l'assaut la dette et
donc elle ya eu en réalité une
négociation il ya eu une avancée sur la
partie de prise en compte de la dette
et puis eu un début de discussion qui
vient maintenant sur une nouvelle
convention collective des personnels
donc du transport ferroviaire
pour l'instant on est ce donc vous
regrettez pas ce mouvement qui était pas
compris par tout le monde et il ya eu ce
qu'a donné l'impression de pas réussir
finalement quel est ce qu'il a donné
moi je pense qu'il a mis en avant le
fait qu'on avait une nouvelle réforme
dans cette secteur ferroviaire qu'ils
allaient porter atteinte à un moment
donné où il ya des problèmes de gaz à
effet de serre d'empreinte carbone
d'accès aux services publics d'ailleurs
on voir dans notre région qui a des gars
qui aujourd'hui vont connaître des
menaces en termes de fréquence ou dans
les trains il n'y aura moins ou plus du
tout de contrôleurs l'avait pas vraiment
la réponse à la question est donc on n'a
pas eu un gouvernement qui a su prendre
les réponses qui convenait la situation
du modèle ferroviaire nicolaï on n'a pas
senti la cfdt toujours en ligne avec la
cgt sur ce conte qui là est ce que ça
dit que la grève ou la manifestation en
france ça commence à ne plus être larmes
que c'était précédemment
c'est un des outils du rapport de forces
la greffe ou la manifestation mais c'est
pas le seul outil du rapport de force et
on peut le voir à certains moments la
concertation être ensemble avoir
beaucoup d'adhérents ce sont les bases
du rapport de force pour une
organisation syndicale la grève et la
manifestation c'est pour revendiquer que
chose très précis ce qui explique à des
moments en tout cas pour la cfdt ce qui
peut expliquer à des moments
effectivement qu'on soit pas tout à fait
en phase avec le moment on descend dans
la rue avec la cgt avec fo etc
c'est il faut choisir parce qu'il faut
pas se conter ce conte est trop faible
un certain moment si important de ne pas
montrer effectivement une certaine force
de faiblesse mais parce que le travail
du syndicalisme ça se fait dans les
boîtes avant tout avec les travailleurs
et ont construit les revendications et
les réponses avec ceux qui sont
concernés par les problématiques
l'idée c'est bien là que ça se passait
dans les entreprises edouard guerrero on
dit parfois que en france ont manifesté
beaucoup et qu'on négocie peu et dans
d'autres pays ont négocié plus c'est
qu'on manifeste - et fo a pas toujours
été non plus sur la ligne des
manifestations très fréquentes ou des
grèves
c'est quoi votre position votre vision à
vous on peut plus manifester comme avant
en tout cas ça ne sert plus à la même
chose alors ma vision c'est d'abord pas
ma vision c'est la vision de bien sûr la
grève la manifestation
c'est un aboutissement de quelque chose
c'est un négocie on négocie toujours et
un moment donné quand on peut plus faire
autrement on fait la grève et la
manifestation sur le cas de la sncf par
exemple ça fait des années quand même
qu'on travaille qu'on travaille que les
gouvernements travaillent sous
l'ouverture du marché de la sncf
privatisation la sncf
ça fait des années les gouvernements les
uns et les autres ont travaillé sur le
sujet mais c'était pas la peine
sous couvert d'ouverture au marché de
en l'air 122000 statut de
cheminot c'était pas du tout utile ce
gouvernement s'est attaqué au statut des
cheminots
il n'y avait pas utilité pour ça bon
comme comme les syndicats ne pas lui
faire la grève comme leslie feist et ne
répond pas vraiment mais non mais ban a
bien fallu manifester et faire la grève
pour défendre son statut le cheminot
parce que sinon parce que négociations
ils ont eu lieu elles ont eu lieu les
négociations dans les ministères avec
les directions y ait des alertes ya eu
tout un tas de choses que des faits et
aux l'aboutissement c'est la grève et la
manifestation alors sur le transport
bien entendu mais elle est si lisa
tuttle à gaza on a eu on a une sensation
souvient les plus anciens d'entre nous
se souviennent de la réforme des aides
des retraites ou le vêtement la
population était derrière la le pays
avait été bloqué toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion montraient que la population
était derrière les glisse dominique
andolfatto sur la sncf sk une bascule
est-ce qu'on est sur une bascule dans la
vie syndicale française ou d'un coup il
ya une population qui est beaucoup moins
derrière un mouvement revendicatif je
pense pas que c'est conjoncturel un fait
hier il ya une évolution qui fut le
premier de fonds fête ses clés les
syndicats peut-être qu'on reviendra
là-dessus ont perdu beaucoup d'adhérents
non plus les années le nombre
d'adhérents qui avait autrefois est donc
ce que j'appellerai les manifestations
les grèves à peu près ce bouton c'est à
dire que celle de national qui décide de
la grève ou qui décide une manifestation
s'il n'y a pas de relais à la base si
les gens se sent pas concerné
directement par la motivation de ce
mouvement ils ne suivent pas donc cesser
grèves presse-bouton ça ça ne fonctionne
pas cela étant le
le résultat de la grève des cheminots
nenê pas si si négatif que cela parce
qu'en fait il tout n'a pas été perdu
pour les cheminots comme on l'a dit
qu'il ya une certaine pression du
gouvernement
il ya beaucoup de on va beaucoup
discuter maintenant de la convention
collective et rien ne nous dit que
finalement on va pas retrouver dans la
convention collective qui avait dans le
statut c'est vrai que pour là bas je
pense que la grève il ya le sentiment
que la grève a été perdu bon cela étant
il ya des négociations qui sont en cours
et peut-être que tout n'a pas été
vraiment perdu dans ce conflit il y
avait aussi l'idée qu'à un moment donné
le pouvoir et nouveau pouvoir décider
que les syndicats représentés pas le
pays réel et que donc on allait le faire
sans eux
est ce que vous êtes le pays réel lors
nicolas ly est ce que l on sait par
exemple dans les manifestations il ya
souvent beaucoup de gens du monde du
public puisqu'il demande du privé qui
ont plus de mal à manifester est ce que
vous êtes le pays réel ou est-ce que
vous êtes une partie seulement du pays
alors on n'est pas à quelques heures de
votre émission finalement ce n'est pas
forcément tout le pays mais on
représente il ya 70 % de salariés et
d'agents qui votent aux élections
professionnelles il faut le rappeler
pour les organisations syndicales
quelle qu'elle soit je pense qu'on peut
quand même se dire que les syndicats
montrent ce que sont les travailleurs en
france aujourd'hui on est en lien
extrêmement direct puisque on est dans
les entreprises il faut pas oublier que
nous représentants du personnel ce sont
avant tout des salariés qui sont dans
les entreprises dans les dans les boîtes
souvent et puis des agents qui sont dans
les services ils sont ivy veut ce que
vivent les autres il les représente
donc moi j'accepte absolument pas qu'on
puisse dire que qu'on représente pas les
français au travail que ce soit en
activité ou non d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui on a ans % d'adhérents c'est
vrai c'est peu c'est trop peu de points
faibles un taux de sa vie dedic
alisation relativement faible par
rapport à d'autres pays mais parce qu'on
n'est pas constitué de la même façon et
parce que les droits finalement
bénéficier à tous ce qui n'est pas le
cas ailleurs
les français savent pas que dans
certains pays pour on n'a plus de droit
on n'obtient plus des choses si on est
adhérent alain syndicats quand les
syndicats lankais d'une c'est pas vrai
c'est par exemple ce n'est pas exact
d'accord moi je pensais ça non
ce que disent les français c'est cela et
notamment les syndicalistes français ça
ça nous ça nous rassure mais non c'est
faux dans les autres pays
l'ailier droit sont pas soumis à la
cymbale réalisation non d'accord donc
voilà on vient on vient de tuer une idée
reçue
vous êtes le pays réel philippe texier
ou pas le syndicalisme et à la cgt à
l'intérieur est un élément de la
démocratie de la démocratie sociale
certes on n'a pas le même rôle que ceux
qui assument les responsabilités
politiques
le législateur l'état les collectivités
mais comme le disait on peut dire que
compte tenu du faible participation aux
élections ils sont pas forcément le pire
ennemi mais le syndicalisme depuis sa
création et au fil des avancées sociales
et je veux pas parler de la sécurité
sociale où il ya des administrateurs des
caisses de la sécurité sociale ou le
paritarisme fait que syndicats de
salariés syndicats d'employeurs ensemble
aborde se concertent
alors avec des débats des désaccords
profonds quelquefois sur la question la
formation professionnelle et sur la
question de l'emploi donc le
syndicalisme assument des
responsabilités à la fois de défense
mais aussi des responsabilités au sens
de la politique publique
lorsqu'un salarié est confronté un
licenciement qui va l'accompagner au
moment de la discussion que le patron à
conseiller du salarié qui va apprécier
une situation dans un conflit sera
contrat de travail c'est le conseiller
prud'homme donc voyez les prérogatives
du syndicalisme sont un élément de la
démocratie alors après il ya un élément
incontournable sur lequel il faut pas
tergiverser dans notre pays
plus de 50% des salariés travaillent
dans des entreprises de moins de 50
salariés
et lorsqu'on va dans les moins de 20 ans
on va se retrouver sur des pourcentages
de 25 30%
le syndicalisme est née en même temps
que l'industrialisation en même temps
que deux groupes
ac c'est en même temps que la machine
numérique est donc aujourd'hui le
syndicalisme est confronté à répandent à
l'atomisation la dénonciation du travail
et aussi à une individualisation du
travail
donc pour nous c'est des défis nouveaux
qui sont posées pour faire bouger de
certaines questions vous me faites les
transitions de l'émission philippe ex
que sur les défis nouveaux
effectivement vous le disiez il ya des
grands enjeux
on parlait de l'environnement par les
toutes ces choses là dans des moments où
le message politique permanence et il
faut réformer le pays
est ce que les syndicats se sentent
parfois un peu montré du doigt edouard
guerrero en tout cas stigmatiser sur
cette idée que les syndicats seraient
des freins à la réforme alors que le
pays doit se réformer veut se réformer
et vous vous empêcherez les réformes en
fait
alors ça c'est vraiment une image qui
est colporté depuis quelques temps d'
moi j'ai vu depuis que je suis arrivé à
l'union départementale tant que sur la
terre on me dit ça ça fait un petit bail
maintenant mais les syndicats ils ont
construit l'histoire de france je vais
vous donner un exemple
c'est sur une idée de force ouvrière
qu'on a constitué la caisse d'assurance
chômage par exemple andré bergeron à
l'époque en par là qu'un ministre ou
avec un président et cette idée fait son
chemin et on monte la caisse d'assurance
chômage s'ils en parlent ça veut dire
qu'il n'est pas dans l'opposition ça
veut dire qu'il est dans une forme de il
n'ya pas l'opposition ces conclusions de
cette idée dans l'organisation de dire à
un moment donné à une pleine période
donnée il ya des personnes des salariés
les travailleurs qui se retrouvent sans
emploi
que peut-on faire pour eux pour les
protéger pour les protéger des aléas de
la vie la sécurité sociale qui évoquait
philippe tout à l'heure c'est quoi la
sécurité sociale c'est quelque chose
qu'on nous envie de le monde entier est
aujourd'hui en france on veut là on veut
là des structures rire on veut la tuer
donc ces grandes idées nous les
syndicats nous y participons quand il
parle de conseillers de salariés ce sont
des adhérents des militants dans les
entreprises qui vont qui vont défendre
les autres seul en haute saône avec les
syndicats on joue un rôle très important
en france par celui dans l'après-guerre
dans le développement économique de la
france et social est-ce que leur nicolaï
vous y pensez vous à grands enjeux qui
vont venir maintenant on sait que la
france est traversée par tout ça il ya
l'environnement des migrations au site
aujourd'hui sont quelque chose
d'important et qui peuvent impacter le
monde du travail par exemple
bien sûr au delà delà de la bataille
dans les entreprises que vous menez est
ce qu'il ya ça aussi dans vos syndicats
oui
le développement durable la question de
l'environnement elle traverse tous les
chantiers syndicaux aujourd'hui il n'ya
pas d'emplois sur une planète morte
donc même temps on a souvent trouvé des
syndicats pas toujours du côté de
l'environnement parce qu'ils sont
parfois au soutien des salariés aussi
dans certains cas quand il avait des
entreprises polluantes ou des choses
comme ça mais on peut tout à fait c'est
pas antinomiques on peut être en soutien
des salariés et réfléchir avec eux à
comment une entreprise peut évoluer pour
être dans une responsabilité
environnementale et c'est ce qu'on fait
au quotidien les équipes sont
demandeuses de la question
environnementale et de réfléchir
ensemble là dessus voyage était arrivé
un petit peu quelque chose ce ne sont
pas les salariés qui polluent
entendons-nous bien il ya un moment
donné une entreprise je pense savoir à
quelle entreprise vous pensiez et non à
un moment donné et avant donne une
entreprise qui polluent vous savez les
salariés ils sont sous la subordination
de leur employeur ils font ce qu'on leur
demande de faire un
après il ya une idée une idée qui suit
son chemin en ce moment bien sûr que
tout le monde d'aujourd'hui prend
conscience de ce qui se passe sur la
planète
c'est un enjeu d'évolution pour les pour
les syndicats philippe texier ça va être
vraiment un enjeu fort pour vos
syndicats
oui oui je pense que il ya aucun acteur
qui est qui qui pourra avancer sans
prendre en compte les questions
économiques environnementales et
sociales
mais fo faut mener ça de front c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
sur 100 euros 1 qui reviennent aux
actionnaires du de bénéfices d'une
entreprise
il y en a 67 qui vont aux actionnaires
27 qui restent dans l'entreprise et 6
qui vont salariés donc on a un modèle
économique qui en ce moment privilégie
la rémunération actionnaires au
détriment de l'environnement et des
salaires et de la formation
donc il faut regarder cette façon
beaucoup plus équilibré il en va
évidemment de des transports on voit la
place que peut occuper le transport
ferroviaire dans des transports propres
d'aménagement du territoire
on voit la place aussi de quelle
industrie mais on parle de l'industrie
qui pollue mais aussi je pense à
l'industrie à l'agroalimentaire
je pense aux catastrophes sanitaires je
pense à l'eau et je pense aussi à
l'énergie certains en effet il ya besoin
de regarder du point de vue de l'énergie
comment envisager une place du nucléaire
autre qu une place dominante mais qui a
une vraie approche de mixité des
différentes sources d'énergie avec une
place de l'un des énergies renouvelables
nouvelle et ça et ça dans une maîtrise
publique parce que selah sue petit jouet
déterminer ce qui a besoin que sur des
sujets aussi fondamentaux que l'énergie
les transports la santé l'information
il ya besoin d'une intervention publique
forte et on peut ne pas laisser des
multinationales décider de la vie ou de
la mort de certaines entreprises on en a
quelques-unes dans la région qui sont
sous le coup de décision de
multinationales et de mise en oeuvre
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire on
va on va évoluer on va le faire vous
vous observez les syndicats et leur
fonctionnement et puis sur sur du long
terme
est-ce que 1 est ce que c'est un enjeu
de est ce qu'il est ce qu'ils sont
sincères de leur point de vue j'aurais
presque envie de dire ils sont peut-être
trop sincère parce qu'en fait il faut
pas que les syndicats confondent leur
rôle avec celui qu partis politiques ou
de laboratoire d'idées et c'est leur
vrai boulot c'est de défendre les
intérêts des salariés dans l'entreprise
défense déjà individuelles et
collectives
c'est leur première besogne d'ailleurs
pour faire allusion un vieux texte de la
cgt la charte à la charte d'amiens et
donc moi je les inciterai d'abord plutôt
à se préoccuper de de recruter des
adhérents
parce que c'est la clef de de celle des
filles vraiment majeurs auxquels ils
sont confrontés dans les pays de l' ocde
seule la turquie fait moins bien que
nous en terme de syndicalisation
donc on va falloir faire le même sillon
pour essayer d'en comprendre voilà donc
c'est un vieux gros challenge mais
peut-être qu'ils ont droit de réfléchir
il faut qu'il réfléchisse sur les grands
enjeux qui se posent à la société pour
la société mais avant tout c'est
défendre les salariés à la base les
questions du travail ils doivent avant
tout se considérer comme des groupes
d'intérêts qui défendent et saddam il
nous reste peu de temps d'émission mais
vous voulez réagir
oui mais je les salariés d'aujourd'hui
sont peut-être pas forcément seulement
cantonnée à une défense immédiate de
leurs intérêts et vous avez raison le
rôle du syndicat c'est défendre les
intérêts moraux et matériels des
syndicats mais les salariés aujourd'hui
qui rentre dans la vie active est arrivé
aussi avec dans la tête
d'autres problématiques que peut-être
leurs aînés et les questions
d'environnement les questions y compris
de citoyenneté
de pouvoir prendre la parole moi je
reviens je suis alors c'est moi qui vais
conclure pour vous parce que je vais
faire le lien avec les missions qu'on a
fait sur l'environnement il ya une
semaine dans lequel les gens nous
disaient les nouveaux salariés qui
rentre dans les entreprises parce qu'on
avait des représentants des entreprises
ont aussi de nouvelles préoccupations et
finalement on voit que nos deux
émissions sur le même sujet de ce peut
se rejoindre
je vous redonne pas la parole est d'or
guerrero parce que l'émission a terminé
merci à tous les cas d'être venus
débattre sur ce débat qui pourrait être
beaucoup plus long bon dimanche
au revoir et merci